I'm talking to you this morning from
Dublin which is sort of doubly poignant
I was only talking to bite him last
night to someone as we passed the bank
in which she worked and in central
Dublin and he worked for arty television
and radio here in Dublin TV do
particularly before he came to England
so Dublin was very much part of his life
although he was born in Limerick but I
you know for me he was the Dom he was
the head of the Mafia and if you got
Terry's blessing that was the biggest
biggest thing you could want being a
young broadcaster from Ireland and I
used to present a program called open
air which he would never appear on when
I came to England first of all and I
would have been by 26 and he wouldn't
appear on but when I met him at a
function once and I said Mike if my
husband lived here in this program he
said it shouldn't be called open air
should be called open wound all you do
is discuss things and tear programs
apart of whatever but he came on and he
did a special and he just called me big
a monkey I thought it was even before I
was big but he always called me play
game and all the time and the thing that
I loved about him was listening to a
stir there he was so indiscreet a gossip
defies everything he talked by the
industry we've both just filmed finished
a film in series and when I last saw him
in November
I said hey hi how did you cope that
filming is absolutely awful it's so
tiring it's old knackering and and we
would just [ __ ] about how awful it was
to go out and film the series like
difficult it was i disorganized people
were I would stand Abidin Esther was
sane by them doing takes won't take them
I never anything I just won't do it for
them I just say that's it that shall not
move on people would say you know if
you're filming and you you know you get
out of a car or something
that isn't what they do they film your
hand on me they do it like 17 times your
hand was on the handle of the card and
your foot is shot going out of the car
and and then they may or may not these
films but what what is two seconds on
screen can take 45 minutes to film
and Terry had bad knees and him and I
had baton comb and I had knee trouble
once and he went on the NEA he
recommended me to the chief surgeon to
go and see and sorted item whatever and
it was very good like daddy you know
I've been to his home even very Eve is a
most marvelous host and just very
laid-back he was a very successful man
not only in broadcasting he had
businesses as well and he enjoyed the
fruits of his labors and a very
tight-knit family and my heart was like
to lady Helen and the boys he was a very
much a family man and when I say when I
call him the Dom very much the Dom in
his family and in the business I think
particularly to some of the Irish
broadcaster so he took under his wing I
mean from for me give it gave me his
blessing I mean to get his blessing you
know was was a marvelous marvelous thing
yeah well that's that's an interesting
thing though I mean because I mean you
know better than most that this is a
business where there is an awful lot of
competition and as a result an awful lot
of rivalry in an awful lot of
backstabbing and you know you were in
some respects you know poaching on this
territory a little bit as any is any
young broadcaster is when they start out
to the to the older people in the
industry and yet he seems that he's not
fazed by rivalry but happy to to help
people and coax people along in the
business well I think it's a sign of
people who are very good he was
confident in his own abilities and he
knew he was significantly different and
you know the great broadcasters that I
that I know so Terry and there's
momentum again another Irishman in a way
they were so led back some people may
see it as Lee as he as I thought I was
there because you can't decide like an
insult but they were efficient they were
very efficient and everything that they
did and like you know my here it was my
hair from up buddy because he didn't if
a monkey's I'm really sorry I find this
and to be difficult on number of points
we I was very friendly with them but all
so being Irish we swear a lot and his
conversations you know beautiful swear
it's like father Ted swearing it's not
really horrible swearing
he's you know we are easy the person
that could have could have used swear
words and a very lovely descriptive
poetic way he was a bit of a poet as
well he loved language and being on the
radio
beautiful loose dulcet tones he was so
at home in the radio and it was like
music listening to him on the radio he's
just been part of our lives for for so
long you know to been around he was
enjoying his retirement but he would do
certain films series and and various
other things and and we look back now
and maybe you know the bad back which
kept him off children in need the last
time maybe that wasn't what would be at
first thought it was and you know what
when I last saw him in November he
looked so well he he was wonderful I
knew you'd trouble with his knees I
still could see him shuffling around oh
sorry but what you still there because I
thought still here you still there yeah
right so but you know a lovely lovely
man an institution and look you know
what we all appear in the TV and you had
a lovers are lovers
but I love them I just loved them um
it's interesting when you when you work
in this business you learn a lot don't
you from from other people I certainly
learned a lot from watching you over the
years i'm and and i wonder what you've
taken from him i've taken from him to be
yourself you see anybody that reads the
script can be replaced but if you do
Oteri's way and you be yourself
you're much harder to replace and he's
replaceable certainly someone we will
never replace a man thank you and as you
say I know it's a difficult view because
you knew him so well but thank you as
always